et avec nous aujourd'hui pour ce club
Loïc senior bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pour parole de
renaissance le parti de la majorité
présidentielle Gabriel Thierry Houari
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être là pour
paroles du Parti socialiste et Isabelle
verra Masson bonjour merci d'être là
spécialiste en communication on aura
besoin de vos lumières dans ce débat
puisqu'on va parler avec vous de la
réforme des retraites présentées cette
semaine en conseil des ministres à la
rive la semaine prochaine au Parlement
mais le gouvernement peut-il encore
convaincre les Français et on va voir ça
puisque vous êtes dans une opération
pédagogique dans la majorité Loïc senior
et on va le voir tout de suite puisque
Audrey vous vous avez suivi un ministre
qui est chargé de convaincre les
Français du bien fondé de cette réforme
c'est Gabriel Attal oui il fait partie
de quelques ministres qui ont le droit
de monter au front sur le sujet alors on
l'a suivi dans une commune rurale près
de 3000 habitants la commune a placé
Marine Le Pen en tête au second tour de
la présidentielle je vous propose de
regarder notre reportage avec Adrien
pain
la scène a des allures de grands débat
Gabriel Attal en Brad chemise au milieu
d'une soixantaine de personnes pour
défendre la réforme des retraites moi
j'ai pas l'exemple de réforme des
retraites qui se soit faite sans
manifestations et sans mobilisation
massive le ministre des comptes publics
fait partie des rares privilégiés
autorisés par l'Elysée et Matignon à
monter au front sur le sujet et on peut
dire qu'il mouille beaucoup le maillot
17h15 les questions d'actualité viennent
de s'achever à l'Assemblée pas la
journée de Gabriel Attal son cortège
prend la direction d'un village près de
Troyes à deux heures de route de Paris
il poursuit le rythme qu'il s'est
lui-même fixé une réunion publique par
semaine mais en chemin le temps d'une
pause la réforme s'invite déjà à la
télévision des députés de la majorité
comme Patrick Vignal annonce qu'il ne
voteront pas la réforme en l'état il est
exigeant il fait des propositions c'est
très bien on peut pas d'un côté nous
dire tout le temps vous avez une
majorité de godillot de PLAYMOBIL
propose jamais une question qui bouge
jamais une oreille etc et puis quand il
y a des députés qui disent bah moi j'ai
des exigences j'ai besoin de garantie
pour voter un texte expliquer que tout
d'un coup c'est la France c'est la crise
il faut écouter les députés il faut
écouter les Français c'est pour ça que
je me déplace partout sur le terrain
voilà moi j'ai pas été je me suis pas je
me suis pas lancé là-dedans pour rester
dans mon bureau
parler avec moi-même franchement je
m'ennuierais un peu en fait alors pour
ne pas s'ennuyer le voici à
Saint-Parres-lès-Vaudes commune rurale
de l'ancien bassin de la bonneterie qui
a placé Marine Le Pen en tête à la
présidentielle il est invité par une
députée les républicains c'est le
ministre qui a souhaité venir dans le
département donc je l'ai juste reçu ben
parce que c'est républicains voilà un
ministre se déplace dans ma
circonscription et c'est important
d'être là de le recevoir de discuter
avec lui d'échanger entre les deux non
non pas du tout mais alors vraiment pas
du tout non et dans la salle même si
beaucoup sont pour la réforme les
inquiétudes sont nombre pénibilité
emploi des seniors et bien sûr inégalité
24 heures plus tôt Franck ryester son
collègue a concédé que les femmes
seraient plus impactés par la réforme
que les hommes pourquoi en plus avec une
nouvelle réforme on va travailler plus
et en plus les femmes travailleront
encore plus Gabriel Attal a peaufiner
les contre-arguments pour éteindre ce
début d'incendie dans cette réforme il y
a énormément de progrès pour les femmes
je donne un exemple la retraite minimum
à 1200 euros je parlais tout à l'heure
elle va bénéficier deux fois plus aux
femmes qu'aux hommes convaincu je ne
sais pas parce que je reste une personne
assez sceptique mais voilà donc ça a
déjà enrichi pas mal mon point de vue
donc je vais pouvoir y réfléchir
davantage et voilà c'était bénéfique
globalement j'ai aimé cette proximité
face au gouvernement avec le
gouvernement donc voilà je le remercie
pour ça également je pense que c'est
quand même un exercice qui est courageux
voilà
moi ça a répondu quand même
à des attentes pour le ministre l'OB
n'était pas uniquement de convaincre
du bien-fondé de la réforme parce que je
sais c'est qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
sont arrivés ici en étant opposé à la
réforme mais je viens pas uniquement
dans une logique de me dire je cherche à
convaincre j'ai aussi dans une logique
de me dire je cherche à comprendre à
entendre ce qui se passe dans le pays
comment les Français voient cette
réforme qu'on puisse en tirer des
conséquences et des conclusions ensuite
dans notre travail au niveau national et
même s'il n'est pas celui qui porte la
réforme il promet que c'est remontées de
terrain pourront donner lieu à des
amendements lors de l'examen du texte au
Parlement
majeur pour l'exécutif pour la majorité
présidentielle la pédagogie tant que
cette réforme oui c'est l'un des enjeux
majeurs en tout cas faire de cette
réforme une réforme compréhensible
notamment sur les trois grands principes
rendre le système équilibré parce qu'on
sait qu'il ne le sera pas d'après les
différentes études et notamment celle du
corps bien qu'elles soient parfois
contestée par les oppositions quand on
regarde les huit scénarios du corps je
vais revenir dessus et à chaque fois le
système étant déséquilibre
le deuxième objectif voilà je savais que
ça serait contester le deuxième objectif
c'est de rendre le système plus juste
parce qu'on oublie souvent de dire que
le système actuel il n'est pas juste il
n'est pas juste notamment pour certaines
catégories de la société et notamment
les femmes donc il faut aller tendre
vers plus de justice sociale pour les
femmes pour les personnes et les
travailleurs en situation de travail
pénible de cari arrachées de carrière
longue ou commencer bien avant l'âge de
16 ans parmi certaines générations de
nos de nos aînés donc il faut faire
comprendre ces messages et puis ensuite
il y a la pédagogie et on l'a vu avec
reportage avec Gabriel Attal dans l'Aube
il faut faire de la pédagogie sur les
particularismes les particularités de
chacun parce que on a ouvert un champ
très large voir un débat de de société
ou parfois on va un peu en parallèle du
débat de la réforme des retraites en
elle-même et on parle beaucoup de notre
relation au travail et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs ce qu'il faudrait ouvrir
comme comme chantier de réflexion c'est
déjà un peu le cas dans le Conseil
national de la refondation avec un gros
chantier sur notre rapport au travail
après la pandémie mais on voit notamment
chez les jeunes chez les seniors aussi
qui veulent aussi parfois mixer mêlés
l'emploi et un départ anticipé à la
retraite c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
propositions faites dans le texte donc
oui faire de la pédagogie sans tomber
dans les contre-vérités ayant un débat
ouvert front direct et constructif
notamment et on l'attend avec impatience
dans la majorité mais j'imagine aussi
chez les autres positions un débat
nourri au Parlement parce que il y a la
rue il y a les médias il y a le débat
d'idées qui peut avoir lieu mais c'est
surtout à la fin les parlementaires qui
feront la loi et on l'espère dans le
meilleur esprit je vais vous laisser
débattre
à l'ossignan
je trouve ça extrêmement cynique
évidemment de présenter cette réforme
comme une réforme de justice c'est tout
sauf une réforme de justice donc il y a
des arguments qui sont dans le débat
depuis un moment évidemment sur la
question de la pénibilité sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui les ouvriers les
catégories de population les plus
populaires vivent moins longtemps et
vivent moins longtemps en bonne santé
le chiffre notamment de 25% des plus
précaires des 5% les plus précaires qui
sont déjà morts en fait à 64 ans donc et
on n'ose parler d'une réforme qui de
justice quand on repousse l'âge alors
qu'au contraire ça accroît de manière
terrible les inégalités de vie et
ensuite qui sont ces personnes parce que
c'est important les 5% les plus
fréquents
je vous parle je vous parle de 5% des
personnes qui arrivent à l'âge non mais
attendez je vous ai laissé terminé je
vais non mais je vous ai laissé terminé
parce que les gens imaginent
un certain nombre de choses donc je vais
aller demander de me laisser terminer et
pour répondre à ça et ça renforce
évidemment les inégalités de vie à
partir du moment où vous repoussez l'âge
de départ à la retraite sans prendre de
manière absolument ambitieuse les
questions de pénibilité et ensuite sur
l'égalité homme-femme pardon mais là
aussi c'est un vrai scandale
deux ministres de la République ont
reconnu ces derniers jours que c'était
une réforme qui allait pénaliser les
femmes tu parles évidemment de Franck
Riester et je parle de Clément bonne
donc on est dans un gouvernement je
parle même plus de la grande cause du
quinquennat qui reconnaît qu'on est dans
une réforme qui va pénaliser les femmes
pourquoi parce que si on prend la
régénération 1980 les femmes vont devoir
travailler huit mois de plus que les
hommes ça repousse de quatre mois pour
les hommes huit mois pour les femmes
donc clairement sur une réforme anti
féministe on est sur une réforme qui
creuse les in qualité de genre c'est
reconnu par deux ministres du
gouvernement et ça ne paraît pas
scandaleux c'est à dire que les femmes
sont tellement devenues la quantité
négligeable des politiques de ce
gouvernement que ça paraît relativement
acceptable de dire on va demander aux
femmes bah oui un petit peu plus
d'efforts mais où on est je trouve ça
profondément scandale et donc évidemment
mon homologue va me rétorquer que cette
réforme est un grand progrès pour les
femmes ça a été cité sur la question de
du des 1200 euros du minimum contributif
ça c'est fou de dire que ça va concerner
majoritairement les femmes pourquoi
parce que les femmes aujourd'hui elles
ont des carrières hachées elles ont des
carrières hachées donc ce ne sont pas
celles qui bénéficieront des 1200 euros
qui concernent les carrières complètes
donc il faut arrêter de mentir aux gens
il faut arrêter aussi se cynisme de
présenter la réforme comme une réforme
de justice sociale assumer que c'est une
réforme de d'équilibre financier une
réforme tout simplement qui vise à
maintenir qui vise à maintenir l'image
de réformiste du chef de l'État à
l'encontre de la vie de tous les
syndicats à l'encontre de ce que la
grande majorité des Français et à
l'encontre évidemment de la justice
sociale juste une chose oui
il y a surtout la question du départ
effectif des femmes c'est ça qu'il faut
regarder dans l'étude d'impact parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a l'âge légal de
départ que l'on reporte avec
l'augmentation des annuités rapidement
avec l'accélération de la réforme
Touraine que votre partie a proposé et à
voter il y a quelques années mais il y a
surtout l'âge effectif mais c'est ça
qu'il faut le regarder dans l'étude
d'impact et qu'il faut sans doute
complété par rapport à ce qui a été dit
par les deux ministres il y a un âge
effectif de départ pour les femmes qui
est inférieur avec cette réforme qu'il
ne l'est aujourd'hui donc c'est ça la
justice sociale pour les femmes elle
continueront à partir plutôt et même
plutôt qu'aujourd'hui donc on est dans
une perspective une recherche de justice
je ne dis pas et personne ne dit que
tout est parfait et encore une fois les
parlementaires vont devoir je l'espère
encore aménager améliorer le texte mais
on est dans un âge effectif de départ
pour les femmes avec cette réforme dans
toutes les projections et dès le passage
de cette réforme qui est inférieure à
celui qui l'est aujourd'hui un dernier
mot là sur la réponse sur la question
des femmes alors ce qui se passe en fait
c'est que pour les femmes donc l'âge
légal de départ comme pour tout le monde
et repousser à 64 ans aujourd'hui les
femmes elles partent un petit peu avant
notamment parce qu'elles ont des
trimestres qui sont accordés 8
trimestres au moment de chaque enfant
donc aujourd'hui les femmes qui
pouvaient partir donc les femmes oui
mais elles ne partent pas attendez
attendez elle pouvait partir avant elle
pouvait partir avant à l'âge légal
attendez monsieur va terminer elle
pouvait partir avant j'avais ce droit
aujourd'hui vous lui retirez ce droit
donc vous retirez le droit de partir
plus tôt donc c'est une réforme
inégalitaire mais si puisqu'elle le
pouvait à 62 ans elle ne le pourront
plus puisque on refait laissez-moi
terminer à 64
c'est un choix là je rigole ce n'est pas
un choix donc les femmes qui sont les
outils de partir quand ils le souhaitent
quand elles le souhaitent alors ça c'est
quand on a un métier bien payé dans un
bureau pas pénible parce qu'il y a
énormément les femmes partiront toujours
énormément de femmes qui exercent des
métiers pénible je pense évidemment à
celle qui travaille à l'hôpital je pense
à celle qui travaille dans les EHPAD je
pense à toute la pénibilité du travail
féminin qui est moins bien mesuré moins
pris en compte et donc aujourd'hui vous
dites on vous empêche de partir plus tôt
mais en fait on améliore votre situation
arrêter c'est complètement faux ensuite
alors la pénibilité elle est prise en
compte à la demande des syndicats
réformateurs notamment la CFDT j'avais
deux ministres qui reconnaissent deux
ministres dont un sur ce plateau qui
reconnaissent et ça va pénaliser les
femmes et qu'on leur demande un peu plus
un peu plus des fois les propos de ces
ministres en disant que l'architective
dans l'étude
d'impacter la question Isabelle verra
pas son là
je maintiens sur l'âge légal sur des
volumes que les Français ne maîtrisent
pas parce que en fait on va partir le
problème et les gens s'intéressent à
leur cas individuel et c'est à ça qu'il
faut répondre si on prend des volumes
tellement large et flou et gazeux comme
on fait vous et moi en ce moment là
personne je termine sur là j'ai effectif
aujourd'hui là j'effectif vous savez
pourquoi les femmes vous savez pourquoi
les et vous savez pourquoi les femmes
aujourd'hui elles partent plus tard vous
le savez ou pas dites le moi vous ne
savez pas alors ça c'est d'accord les
femmes parlent plus tard aujourd'hui
parce qu'elles ont des carrières hachées
parce qu'elles ont des revenus qui sont
moindres tout le long de la carrière et
donc aujourd'hui
les femmes et donc il faut regarder
parfois pour pouvoir mesurer les
inégalités de genre monsieur ça montre
bien que vous ne connaissez rien au
sujet parce que la plupart des personnes
qui travaillent dans des bureaux
dans la même catégorie elles sont de 40
% inférieures aux pensions des armes
pourquoi parce que les inégalités
si vous voulez mesurer les inégalités il
faut bien dire qu'il y a des femmes et
des hommes qui sont des jeunes dans des
situations différentes donc les femmes
sont plus souvent à temps partiel les
femmes s'arrêtent de travailler au
moment de l'arrivée des enfants pour la
majorité les femmes en moyenne gagnent
moins que les hommes sur la carrière et
oui je dis les femmes parce que c'est
une réalité et donc arrivé à la
génération
il est plus tard c'est pour ça
l'égalité alors que vous nous empêchez
et on va pas vous mettre d'accord
Isabelle verra Masson
je vais pas vous demander d'arbitrer
Isabelle façon ce n'est pas mais juste
c'est cette question des femmes c'est
vrai qu'elle a surgi sur le débat depuis
la phrase de Franck Ricard sur notre
plateau qui a dit que les phrases
seraient un peu pénalisées est-ce que ça
montre que sur un sujet comme ça toute
erreur de communication peut prendre des
proportions
extraordinaires écoutez moi j'ai vu j'ai
plus envie de prendre un peu de distance
par rapport à c'est pas je vous remercie
de nous en parler en troisième parce
qu'effectivement d'une certaine manière
je vais parler de ce que je viens de
voir la communication politique en
matière de retraite et sur cette réforme
est impossible je tiens à vous de vous
annoncer vous partez d'un combat perdu
d'avance pourquoi bien évidemment parce
que la question des retraites n'est pas
une question populaire et que de toute
façon le message est brouillé par le
fait qu'il y a déjà eu débat sur les
retraites donc vous imaginez qu'au
niveau de la réception c'est ce qui
m'intéresse moi ce qui vous intéresse
d'en parler c'est non pas ce que vous
dites mais c'est la manière dont les
gens vont recevoir ces messages et dans
la communication la question c'est que
pour les metteurs c'est pour l'homme
politique pour les acteurs politiques la
question est d'essayer d'être plus près
de ce que les gens vont pouvoir entendre
et dans en l'occurrence dans ce cas-là
c'est pratiquement impossible parce que
les gens ne comprennent plus entre les
mêmes personnes qui avaient défendu une
réforme des retraites sont les mêmes qui
défendent une autre réforme des
retraites qui est quand même assez
différente ça c'est la première chose
ensuite la question de l'argent qui est
au cœur voilà la question économique est
au cœur des débats est devenu une
question incompréhensible l'argent est
devenu magique depuis de quoi qu'il en
coûte et lorsqu'on parle de milliards et
de milliards franchement les Français
sont peut-être pas
idiot mais enfin en tous cas moi je vais
parler partie de ces de ces Français là
il y a une difficulté totale de
compréhension de la situation et puis
après il y a deux types de discours qui
s'affrontent et ces deux discours qui
s'affrontent sont absolument comment
dirais-je inaudible pour les Français ou
en tous les cas sont sont mis à distance
et le discours de l'exagération et de la
fake news c'est à dire que à force de
dire que c'est pauvres femmes ou c'est
pauvres hommes ont travaillé jusqu'à 77
ans on voit bien qu'on ait plus dans la
on est plus dans la raison on est dans
le mensonge ou dans la fake news on a vu
la manière dont vous avez utilisé la
fameuse information concernant les 5%
les 25% des 5% qui sont des gens qui
n'ont pas travaillé donc on est
totalement en dehors de l'affaire donc
là on est dans un mois je pensais que
c'était plus du tout je pense que quand
vous gagnez 400 euros toute notre vie
c'est qu'on n'est pas de problème
les 5% les plus pauvres c'est ceux-là
et enfin et en face donc la fake news
exagération et l'erreur parce que moi je
pense que tout à fait de manière
spontanée on peut recevoir et enfin il y
a un discours qui est impossible aussi
qui est constamment dans l'élément de
langage évidemment éléments de langage
comment faire pour avoir un discours qui
ne soit pas tenu puisqu'à chaque fois
que vous ne tenez pas vos discours on le
voit pour Richter et bien vous êtes pris
à l'envers parce que des choses ne sont
pas disciples par exemple pourquoi ne
dictons pas écouter un mois de travail
est-ce que c'est si grave c'est pas
possible ou un certain nombre de
discours ne sont pas disciples parce
qu'ils vont être inversés parce qu'ils
vont être détournés parce qu'on est on
est dans un dans un monde où on traite
l'opposé en politique de maudit hein ça
veut dire que la pédagogie
ce qu'il fait d'aller voir les Français
c'est c'est peine perdu c'est peine
perdue c'est pas une perdue alors
maintenant vous allez me dire ils le
font quand même imaginons qu'il ne le
fasse pas hein c'est toujours en
communication c'est toujours ça c'est on
voit bien que la peine est perdue que le
discours est inaudible et alors ce qui
est effrayant c'est de voir qu'en plus
ça s'aggrave c'est-à-dire que c'était de
toute façon inaudible et impossible de
faire accepter cette réforme pour les
raisons que j'ai dites au début mais en
plus ça s'aggrave donc il y a peut-être
des erreurs donc il y a des erreurs
probablement moi je ne suis pas là pour
an des erreurs mais surtout parce que à
chaque fois qu'un message est tenu sur
les retraites les interférences sont
constantes avec la vie la mort la
société on le voit bien sur les femmes
il y a une question d'une femme les
femmes les femmes vous avez raison de
dire on devrait pas dire les femmes
puisque moi je suis une femme qui
travaille jusqu'à 70 ans et chacun
travaille nous dans le dans la recherche
comme dans Simon se bat pour rester au
boulot donc je suis une femme et quand
vous prenez votre retraite en tant que
femme moi j'ai eu trois enfants j'ai des
avantages considérables qui me gênent
presque même si je trouve ça normal
parce que j'ai perdu pas mal de temps
pour élever mes enfants mais donc les
femmes la situation des femmes dans une
société comme la nôtre évidemment elle
est injuste évidemment elle est elle est
ancienne elle n'est pas Hélène sera pas
réussi à mais
mélangez cela avec la question des
retraites on voit bien qu'on est dans la
référence communicationnelle c'est
extrêmement difficile les refraite où on
va régler le problème des femmes et les
problèmes de femmes vont pas être réglés
par les retraites donc interférence
brouillage dans la communication
difficulté de se faire entendre et
considération dans tous les sens empêche
une communication possible alors
peut-être que sur la pédagogie c'est
peine perdue en tout cas quand on s'est
déplacé pour leur reportage on a senti
dans cette petite salle en 60 personnes
une très grosse inquiétude sur le
travail des seniors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
à partir de 55 ans c'est vrai qu'on sait
que la moitié des seigneurs sont
employés de 55 à 62 ans et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est remonté
plusieurs questions étaient posées
là-dessus il y a il y avait beaucoup de
personnes qui avaient des idées des
propositions on en a senti que c'était
vraiment un gros sentiment d'inquiétude
et ils étaient assez contents je dirais
de pouvoir en parler au ministre après
il faut savoir ce qui m'a ce qui va être
fait mais en tout cas c'est un gros
point on sent que je trouve que la
question de la communication est sur les
seniors est très très intéressante parce
qu'en fait en réalité si on arrivait à
se mettre d'accord imaginons la gauche à
droite se mettre d'accord on pourrait
s'attaquer aux questions qui sont
douloureuses qui sont divisées par
exemple les fins de de vie
professionnelle c'est à dire qu'en fait
en réalité si on admettait pour que on
vit plus longtemps qu'on la meilleure
état qu'on peut travailler quelques mois
de plus parce qu'en fait il s'agit de
moins de plus pour la plupart des
Français pourquoi pas et à ce moment-là
attaquons-nous au vrai question à mon
avis qui sont même même moi même les
femmes ou qui travaillent dans la
recherche dans la fin de carrière
professionnelle n'est pas la même que le
début et donc on devrait s'appeler à ce
genre de choses et ça c'est impossible
parce que justement la communication est
impossible c'est et je trouve que la
communication devient politique et là
elle devient politique c'est elle est
intéressante si je peux me permettre
juste sur la question des femmes parce
que je trouve ça extrêmement important
je suis d'accord avec vous sur le fait
que la question des retraites va pas
régler les problèmes d'inégalité de
revenus tout au long de la carrière
qu'on a un sujet de revalorisation des
des métiers faiblement rémunérés etc des
femmes de s'arrêter de travailler pour
guérir des enfants et des choix et de et
la question de la répartition des tâches
domestiques et familiales qui sera pas
réglée par la question des retraites en
revanche ce qu'on peut dire et c'est ce
que je dis aujourd'hui c'est qu'on peut
avoir des réformes qui pénalise et qui
dégrade la situation des femmes et là
c'est ce face à quoi on est donc on peut
dire que c'est une réforme qui est
inégalitaire qui renforce les inégalités
de genre et il faut pas se cacher
derrière son petit doigt et on est
obligé de considérer effectivement qu'il
y a une situation des femmes comme vous
le dites puisque en réalité ce sont les
femmes qui en moyenne s'arrêtent pour de
travailler pour élever les enfants ce
sont en moyenne les femmes qui passent à
temps partiel dans leur carrière et donc
il y a bien cette généralité à faire
pour comprendre ce qui est en train de
se passer mesurer et résorber les
inégalités de genre et c'est que je vous
laisserai l'inverse Seigneur et après on
avance on revient à la communication la
pédagogie mais je vous laisse répondre
évidemment maintenant sur Gabriel c'est
ce que je disais en introduction c'est
un débat intéressant mais c'est pas le
débat de la réforme des retraites c'est
un débat c'est un débat pardon de vous
le dire Gabriel Siri c'est un débat sur
la relation au travail mais c'est pas ce
que je dis nos caricaturez pas parce que
certains de vos points mais c'est pas le
on va parler allez on va parler de la
communication et évidemment il a une
importance et le ministre qui porte
cette réforme il est en l'occurrence
c'est Olivier du socle le ministre du
Travail et il est devenu la cible de la
gauche oui lui qui se flatte de faire
aboutir les réformes difficiles comme
celle de l'assurance chômage essaye
d'incarner sur celle des retraites même
s'il est pas le ministre le plus connu
du gouvernement le problème c'est qu'il
a un défaut si je puis dire pour porter
ce texte autrement inflammable Oriane
c'est que jusqu'à 2017 période où il a
rejoint Emmanuel Macron Olivier dussobe
faisait partie du Parti socialiste et il
sait souvent opposé aux mesures d'âge et
c'est sur ce point qui appuies ces
ex-camarades a commencé par le premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste c'était
il y a une semaine regarder
je vous ai connu une autre époque où
vous défendiez effectivement les
Français qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt vous défendiez celles et ceux qui le
matin soulève aux aurores prennent le
RER ou le bus celle qui vide nos
poubelles celles et ceux qui
effectivement n'avait que vous pour les
défendre et vous les avez oublié j'ai
honte pour vous on se trouve défendez
aujourd'hui honte de voir que vous avez
renié l'ensemble de vos projets les
procès en trahison je suis immunisé
surtout quand ils viennent par ceux qui
ont vendu la sociale démocratie à
l'extrême gauche pour sauver leur siège
et c'est pas la première fois que son
passé de socialisme Oriane une semaine
plus tôt au Sénat c'est Monique Lubin la
sénatrice socialiste des Landes qui a
évoqué certains de ses amis qui pâtiront
de cette réforme le ministre c'est un
peu agacé lui a répondu un peu sèchement
ça a donné lieu à un échange savourer
les amis que vous avez auquel vous avez
pensé je souhaite pour vous que ce soit
des amis imaginaires parce que le
principal bouger le principal décalage
de leur âge de départ c'est la hausse de
la durée de cotisation vous avez voté en
2013 monsieur le ministre qu'il est doux
à mes oreilles de vous de me faire des
remarques à moi sur ce qu'a fait ma
famille politique et ce que nous avons
voté quand ça vient de vous monsieur le
ministre vous et moi savons très bien
j'ai quelques souvenirs monsieur le
ministre dans le département des Landes
avec un de mes grands anciens qui
s'appelait Henri Emmanuelli et que vous
aimiez beaucoup à l'époque de vous
appréciez beaucoup à l'époque voilà donc
fallait pas me tenter
ça me permet de vous donner une petite
anecdote Oriane on parle d'un autre
temps en 2014 Emmanuel Macron avait
parlé des ouvrières de l'entreprise Gad
comme des familles les traits savaient
beaucoup énervé le député PS Olivier du
socle dont la mère est ouvrière ça avait
donné lieu à un accrochage dans les
couloirs de l'Assemblée nationale et les
deux hommes avaient dû être séparés par
Henri Emmanuelli donc voilà on fait le
on fait le rapprochement en tout cas la
gauche semble s'être donné le mot
puisqu'il y a c'est la sénatrice
communiste captive a pour sopoly qui a
fustigé encore une fois le passé taulier
il y a 10 ans vous étiez le grand
défenseur de la retraite à 60 ans vous
avez changé évidemment Davy entre deux
mais ce n'est pas étonnant de votre part
je l'ai laissé parce que vous voyez même
le président gérarchie un peu choqué la
sortie c'est pas une team un peu facile
cet angle d'attaque en matière de
communication pour la gauche Gabriel
mais c'est difficile quand c'est le
Ministre
en charge à réforme des retraites
effectivement qui quelques années avant
disait l'inverse quand c'est ce ministre
qui
quelques jours avant de rentrer au
gouvernement votait contre le budget
donc évidemment on s'expose à ce genre
de commentaires et à ce genre voilà il
faut bien souligner cette hypocrisie et
en réalité c'est c'est
particulièrement dommageable je crois
mais c'est le propre d'en marche de
toute façon d'avoir récupéré pardon mais
je les appelle des traîtres de gauchers
de droite que de se retrouver dans cette
situation est-ce que ça vous complique
pas un peu le débat et notamment le
débat parlementaire puisque c'est lui
qui va le porter Olivier du xinor Yvette
sans cesse qu'on voyait à son passé et à
ce que la opposition considère comme des
contradictions des revirements on a
besoin
merci imagine hein quelque chose de
gauche mais c'est un peu raté quelque
chose de plus compliqué pour nous de
d'avoir dans nos rangs et au
gouvernement et nous en sommes fiers
quelqu'un qui connaît à la fois
parfaitement le sujet qui a une histoire
politique qui est la sienne et qui a
sans doute fait le choix de quitter un
parti socialiste au bon moment vu l'état
dans lequel il est aujourd'hui soumis à
une alliance électoraliste populiste
dans la nupes et entaché de fraude
interne dont on sait pas réellement qui
est le chef dans ce parti au bord du
précipice donc je préfère que l'île du
soft a fait ce choix avant et ça
explique aussi sans doute cet état dans
le parti du Parti socialiste quelques
choix qui ont été les siens par le passé
ou effectivement la démocratie interne
n'avait pas vraiment lieu dans ce
courant parce que
certains députés certaines députés
c'est quand même rester dans un parti
rester dans un militants vous n'avez pas
de militants
grâce à cela obtenu un certain nombre de
réformes dont l'histoire dira qu'elle a
été donc évidemment les congés payés
la sécurise sociale etc etc qui n'est
pas venu de la droite en général mais
c'est intéressant rapidement voilà parce
que le terme réforme qui à l'époque
qualifiait plutôt justement des réformes
de progrès social vous les avez cités
congés payés etc et devenu aujourd'hui
synonyme de détricotage de toute la
protection sociale qui s'est construit
depuis 1945 et donc on est dans un
version
regarder les chiffres et les indicateurs
économiques depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron
est au pouvoir vous voulez plus de
chômage retournez vos vieilles nuls nous
avons besoin
du chômage allez triche allez on va on
va passer on va continuer à pas de la
réforme de retraite challenge de nos
quotidiens régionaux Audrey
[Musique]